[Music]  it's weird you like hanging out with  animals more than people yeah  well animals get me arrested George he  was 2 years old  George never would have survived on his  own he definitely trusts you last night  George was seven feet weighed 500 pounds  George okay buddy  you're scared it's okay this morning his  nine feet pushing a thousand what's  happening to my friend  familiar with genetic editing changes  will be incredibly unpredictable is he  the only one oh you didn't know about  the 30-foot wolf hello today huh science  experiments falling from the sky having  George on that plane it's a big mistake  I think we'll be all right  let's go save the world  it's coming back to me  you have to evacuate Chicago George  didn't ask for this they're gonna put  them down  that's not happening  [Music]  there's something in the river I was  just thinking the only thing that's  missing right now is the giant crocodile  you